let's go to the front of the week when
on people's minds will go first to our
caller from the 8:45 area code listen
for your area code you won't hear
anything you won't hear a click or a
chime but you'll be on the air when I
mention your area code so who's calling
from 8:45 I was like no that's it I'm
going to find a way to not have to deal
let's see what also security law can you
hear me yeah literally and I'm poor so I
can't even do that so I have to do the
next best thing which is crypto burnsy
well you listen to the right people
I wonder if I people that knows what
they're talking about and there's other
people I bet you could get rich doing
please yeah watch it now watch as I talk
with you and you pay eight four five or
do you want to talk to us or are you
just talking to someone about bicker
pretty much if you knew a b c and d yeah
yes you should we ended i think so they
called us I mean I'm giving you all
right I'm gonna hang up on them 8:45
very interesting hope Bitcoin
investments are going well for you